[Music]  oh it was a beautiful night last night  at the las vegas ballpark and there i  had the honor of playing our national  anthem on my foot the aviators hosting  the el paso chihuahuas again the win  wasn't a factor  lots of people out there high scoring  game aviators won 12 to five thanks to  everybody who came up to say howdy and  uh go aviators oh wow oh wow great job  nate well thank you it's an honor and a  privilege i've been playing the food  since i was in the fifth grade and uh  when you hear uh the national anthem on  a flute which you don't normally hear  and the acoustics of the ballpark you  actually sound better than you might  really be  i doubt that you are quite talented and  i know people enjoy it we love the bow  tie by the way this is my baseball ball  and you even had the beyonce thing going  on with a little wind in your hair yeah  it was just right yeah it was